supreme court justice clarence thomas is  in a wild situation his own health is a  question mark thomas was hospitalized  with flu-like symptoms not coveted  reportedly on antibiotics which of  course you wouldn't use for cobit  at the same time  he has missed a number of days on the  supreme court of hearings because of  what ended up being quite a long  hospitalization at the same time  thomas's wife jenny thomas is now in  serious hot water because text messages  have been uncovered in which she was  openly supportive of the attempted coup  remember donald trump didn't win the  2020 election he tried to remain as  president he had supporters one of those  supporters was jenny thomas which raises  real conflict of interest questions if  you believe clarence thomas should  recuse himself from any case on the  court that even remotely relates to the  2020 election let me know in the  comments